[Musique]
tricher tremper mentir en science la
fraude et la pire des ennemis juillet
2022 la revue scène découvre qu'une
sommité de la recherche sur la maladie
d'Alzheimer aurait falsifié manipuler
ces résultats l'article au cœur de
l'enquête remonte à plus de 15 ans
ce papier n'est pas le moindre c'est un
article fondateur l'un des plus cités en
matière de recherche sur la maladie
d'Alzheimer son auteur Sylvain lesnet en
2006 ce neurobiologiste français devient
célèbre après avoir démontré ce que
d'autres soupçonnaient depuis longtemps
lorsque la protéine amyloïde bêta
s'accumule autour des neurones elle
forme des plaques
c'est alors qu'une cascade s'ensuit des
neurones meurent ce qui provoque la
démence chez la souris
pour simplifier les plaques amyloïdes
peuvent se comparer à un sac de déchets
prétend avoir ciblé le déchet qui
déclenche la maladie c'est l'amyloïde
bêta étoile 56 voilà si la preuve
convaincante la bougie d'allumage qu'on
attendait pour explorer le monde des
amyloïdes pendant 15 ans la vaste
majorité des fonds de recherche est
consacré à cette hypothèse on explore
toutes les formes d'amyloïdes pas
seulement celle de lessiner seul
problème personne arrive à répliquer la
découverte de l'acné maintenant on
comprend mieux pourquoi
pour coller à son hypothèse de départ
Sylvain Lesney aurait assemblé collé des
images provenant de différentes
expériences
[Musique]
quels impacts auront ces soupçons d'un
conduite pour le moment la nouvelle n'a
pas eu des faits au Canada sur le
financement accordé à la recherche sur
la maladie d'Alzheimer par contre les
nouvelles demandes de financement
devront obligatoirement tenir compte de
cette nouvelle réalité
maintenant la vraie question faut-il
remettre en cause nos connaissances sur
la maladie délaisser les études sur la
myolide pas du tout
il faut savoir que la recherche remise
en cause concerne une forme toxique bien
précise la miloïde bêta étoile 56 et
cela fait déjà des années que les
chercheurs ont délaissé cette piste
c'est un coup dur pour la science mais
il invalide pas la recherche faite sur
la centaine d'autres formes d'amyloïdes
il faut rappeler que la méthode utilisée
par l'acné et fiable c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi son étude a été cité plus de
2300 fois ce sont les résultats qui
posent problème
avant même la parution de cette histoire
l'hypothèse de l'amyloïde comme seule
responsable de la maladie commençait
déjà à battre de l'aile la soixantaine
des scènes cliniques pour valider cette
cible thérapeutique ont tous échoué
même la découverte de molécules capable
de bloquer la production de plaques
amyloïdes n'a pratiquement rien donné
il est donc de plus en plus clair que
cette substance n'est pas la seule
responsable de la maladie
l'idée d'une maladie multifactorielle
fait tranquillement son chemin